making his first start in his
professional career
the left-hander aj minter
and here he strikes out runner at second
with two out
a strikeout nzn turner was moving to
third
and muncie comes up empty first and
third one out a double a pass ball to
walk and travis darneau has the chance
to put atlanta on top here in game five
high fly ball into right field back is
bets at the wall it is caught tagging
scoring as freeman on a sack fly by
darneau and the braves strike first in
game five
minter has already matched his career
high or outs picked up in a ball game
and has a one two three second and with
action on the bases first and third only
one out on a base hit the other way by
marcakis so the o2 pitch now with one
out in the inning
that is in the center field to base hit
atlanta
doubles its lead at two to nothing as
the rookie poche comes through on an o2
pitch
this long half inning continues and a
2-2 now
a strikeout nz so dustin may
gives up one peterson trying to get on
and get something started for the
dodgers here in the third inning two-two
pitch is strike three
five strikeouts through two and a third
for minter three-two pitch
minter does battle back
and with that we'll likely get to stay
in now as mookie bence walks to the
plate 3-2 to betts
he struck him out
amazing
aj minter step right up three full
innings seven strikeouts dansby swanson
walked and scored runners on at second
and third one down
and that's off the end of the bat into
right charging it is
betts
and tagging and scoring is ozuna
3 nothing
and they may want to take another look
at that
yeah he's going he's off the back yep
they're going to overturn this
there's a call
two balls in a strike now on seeger hits
one into center field
back is pachay at the wall and it's gone
two to one here in the fourth inning
as seeger gets home run number three of
this lcs
and that ball just kept on carrying
and just got over the wall in center and
from ozuna getting doubled off third to
the next batter at the plate for the
dodgers a home run and it's a one-run
game and will smith will face will smith
the veteran left-hander the 25-year-old
catcher for the dodgers runners on at
first and second there they go
and a high fly ball to left
back at the wall it is gone
will smith
the biggest swing of his young career
and the dodgers jump on top
four to two
here in the sixth
[Applause]
here's a one-one
argument from manager brian snicker yeah
it hit the hit the bat i mean
and they're going to bring him back
that is toward the corner so instead of
being hit by the pitch and standing at
first chris taylor is at second with a
two out double
57 degrees and there's a base hit in the
left
taylor is coming to the plate the throw
by marcakis
cut off
and a two-out rally makes it a three-run
game here in game five
a two-out rbi single he goes
seeger hits one into right center field
this ball is up and out
another home run for corey seeger and
now the dodgers
are blowing it open here in the seventh
locked in
cory seeger five run ball game two on
nobody out three-two pitch
ground ball to third weird turner out at
second and got him both
here is max muncie
and this one is shot in the air to
center back at the wall it is
[Music]
caught for the out
up to grab it
and then takes a seat and nonchalantly
shows the ball of the world and says
that
as he goes up to rob a home run is out
number one the dodgers all-time saves
leader
is into the ball game in a four-run
affair one-two pitch is swung on
and foul tipped into the glove
of will smith and kenley janssen strikes
out the side
to slam the door on game number five